we've spent several videos talking about
the costs of a firm and in particular
we've thought about how marginal cost is
driven by quantity and how average total
cost is driven by quantity and we think
about other average costs as well
now in this video we're going to extend
that analysis by starting to think about
profit
now profit you're probably already
familiar with the term but one way to
think about it very generally it's how
much a firm brings in you could consider
that its revenue minus its costs
minus its costs and a rational firm will
want to maximize its profit
and so to understand how a firm might go
about maximizing its profit or what
quantity it would need to produce to
maximize its profit based on this on its
cost structure we have to introduce
revenue into this model here and in
particular we are going to introduce the
idea of marginal revenue and we're going
to assume that this firm is in a very
competitive market and so it is a price
taker so regardless of how much this
firm produces the incremental revenue
per unit of what it produces maybe this
is a donut company the incremental
amount per donut is going to stay the
same regardless of how much this firm in
particular produces
so let's say that the marginal revenue
in this industry in this market is right
over here so one way to think about it
is this would be the unit price
in that market so let me put this right
up there marginal
revenue
once again for every incremental unit
how much revenue you're going to get so
it would just be the price of that unit
so how much would a rational firm
produce in order to maximize its profit
if the marginal revenue is higher than
the marginal cost well that means every
incremental unit it produces it's going
to bring in some net money into the door
so it's rational for it to do it so it
would keep producing keep producing keep
producing keep producing now it gets
interesting as the marginal cost starts
to approach the marginal revenue as long
as the marginal revenue is higher than
the marginal cost it's rational for the
firm to produce but right at that unit
where the marginal cost is equal to the
marginal revenue
well there on that incremental unit the
firm just breaks even at least on the
margin it might be able to utilize some
of its fixed costs a little bit but then
after that point it makes no sense at
all for it to keep producing why is that
well if the marginal cost is higher than
the marginal revenue that would be like
saying hey i'm going to sell a donut for
a dollar even though that incremental
donut costs me a dollar ten to produce
well no rational person if they want to
maximize their profit would do that
so a rational firm that's trying to
maximize its profit will produce the
quantity where marginal cost intersects
marginal revenue it will produce this
quantity
right over there
now a natural question might be
how much profit will it make from
producing that quantity well all you
have to do is think about this is the
marginal revenue that it gets and
another way you could think about it
because this is constant it's also going
to be the average revenue that it gets
per unit
and this right over here is the average
total cost per unit
and so what you could do is this is how
much it's getting on average per unit
and then multiply that times the number
of units
and what you get is the area
of
this rectangle
so for those of you who are more
visually inclined one way to think about
it is a profit maximizing firm a
rational profit maximizing firm would
want to maximize this area think about
what would happen if they
only produced this much well then
they're giving up a ton of area
then the rectangle would only be this
big
this would be the profit that the firm
is going to be making from those units
and then if it decides for some
irrational reason to produce more than
this quantity that we settled on before
let's say this right over here notice
even though that the base of this
rectangle is longer the height is less
and this would actually have a lower
area
and the reason why i feel very confident
that this will have a lower area
is because in this situation the firm is
losing money on all of these incremental
units where the marginal cost is higher
than the marginal revenue
so big takeaway a rational firm that's
trying to maximize its profit will
produce the quantity where marginal cost
and marginal revenue are equal to each
other